computers used to be as big as a room
but now they fit in your pocket on your
wrist and can even be implanted inside
of your body how cool is that and this
has been enabled by the miniaturization
of transistors which are the tiny
switches in the circuits at the heart of
our computers and it's been achieved
through decades of development and
breakthroughs in science and engineering
and of billions of dollars of investment
but it's given us vast amounts of
computing huge amounts of memory and the
digital revolution that we all
experience and enjoy today but the bad
news is were about to hit a digital
roadblock as the rate of miniaturization
of transistors is slowing down and this
is happening at exactly the same time as
our innovation in software is continuing
relentlessly with artificial
intelligence and big data and our
devices regularly perform facial
recognition or augment our reality or
even drive cars down our treacherous
chaotic roads it's amazing but if we
don't keep up with the appetite of our
software we could reach a point in the
development of our technology where the
things that we could do with software
could in fact be limited by our hardware
and we've all experienced the
frustration of an old smartphone or
tablet grinding slowly to a halt over
time under the ever-increasing weight of
software updates and new features and it
worked just fine when we bought it not
so long ago but the hungry software
engineers have eaten up all the hardware
capacity over time the semiconductor
industry is very well aware of this and
it's working on all sorts of creative
solutions such as going beyond
transistors to quantum computing or even
working with transistors in alternative
architectures such as neural network
to make more robust and efficient
circuits but these approaches will take
quite some time and we're really looking
for a much more immediate solution to
this problem the reason why the rate of
miniaturization of transistors is
slowing down is due to the
ever-increasing complexity of the
manufacturing process the transistor
used to be a big bulky device until the
invent of the integrated circuit based
on pure crystalline silicon wafers and
after 50 years of continuous development
we can now achieve transistor features
dimensions down to 10 nanometers you can
fit more than a billion transistors in a
single square millimeter of silicon and
to put this into perspective a human
hair is 100 microns across a red blood
cell which is essentially invisible is 8
microns across and you could place 12
across the width of a human hair but a
transistor in comparison is much smaller
at a tiny fraction of a micron across
and you could place more than 260
transistors across a single red blood
cell or more than 3,000 across the width
of a human hair it really is incredible
nanotechnology in your pocket right now
and besides the obvious benefit of being
able to place more smaller transistors
on a chip smaller transistors are faster
switches and smaller transistors are
also more efficient switches so this
combination has given us lower cost
higher performance and higher efficiency
electronics that we all enjoy today to
manufacture these integrated circuits
the transistors are built up layer by
layer on a pure crystalline silicon
wafer and in an oversimplified sense
every tiny feature of the circuit is
projected onto the surface of the
silicon wafer and record it in a light
sensor
of material and then itched through the
light-sensitive material to leave the
pattern in the underlying layers and
this process has been dramatically
improved over the years to give the
electronics performance we have today
but as the transistor features get
smaller and smaller we're really
approaching the physical limitations of
this manufacturing technique the latest
systems for doing this patterning have
become so complex that they reportedly
cost more than 100 million dollars each
and semiconductor factories contain
dozens of these machines so people are
seriously questioning is this approach
long-term viable but we believe we can
do this chip manufacturing in a totally
different and much more cost-effective
way using molecular engineering and
mimicking nature down at the nano scale
dimensions of our transistors as I said
the conventional manufacturing takes
every tiny feature of the circuit and
projects it onto the silicon but if you
look at the structure of an integrated
circuit the transistor arrays many of
the features are repeated millions of
times it's a highly periodic structure
so we want to take advantage of this
periodicity in our alternative
manufacturing technique we want to use
self-assembling materials to naturally
form the periodic structures that we
need for our transistors we do this with
the materials that in the materials do
the hard work of the fine patterning
rather than pushing the projection
technology to its limits and beyond
self-assembly is seen in nature in many
different places from lipid membranes to
cell structures so we do know it can be
a robust solution if it's good enough
for nature it should be good enough for
us so we want to take this naturally
occurring robust self-assembly and use
it for the manufacturing of our
semiconductor technology
one type of self-assemble material it's
called a block copolymer consists of two
polymer chains just a few tens of
nanometers in length but these chains
hate each other they repel each other
very much like oil and water or my
teenage son and daughter but but we
cruelly bond them together creating an
inbuilt frustration in the system as
they try to separate from each other and
in the bulk material there are billions
of these and the similar components try
to stick together and the opposing
components try to separate from each
other at the same time and this has a
built-in frustration attention in the
system so it moves around its squirms
into the shape is formed and the natural
self-assemble shape that is formed is
nano scale it's regular is periodic and
it's long range which is exactly what we
need for our transistor arrays so we can
use molecular engineering to design
different shapes of different sizes and
a different periodicity
so for example if we take a symmetrical
molecule where the two polymer chains
are similar lends the natural
self-assemble structure that is formed
is a long meandering line very much like
a fingerprint and the width of the
fingerprint lines and the distance
between them is determined by the length
of our polymer chains but also the level
of built-in frustration in the system
and we can even create more elaborate
structures if we use unsymmetrical
molecules where one polymer chain is
significantly shorter than the other and
the self assemble structure that forms
in this case is with the shorter chains
forming a tight ball in the middle and
it's surrounded by the longer opposing
polymer chains forming a natural
cylinder and the size of this cylinder
and the distance between the cylinders
the periodicity is again determined by
how long we make the polymer chains and
the level of built-in frustration
so in other words we're using molecular
engineering to self-assemble nano scale
structures that can be lines or
cylinders the size and periodicity of
our design we use in chemistry Chemical
Engineering to manufacture the nano
scale features that we need for our
transistors but the ability to self
assemble these lay these structures only
takes us half of the way because we
still need to position these structures
where we want the transistors in the
integrated circuit but we can do this
relatively easily using wide guide
structures that pin down the
self-assembled structures anchoring them
in place and forcing the rest of the
self-assembled structures to lie
parallel aligned with our guide
structure for example if we want to make
a fine 40 nanometer line which is very
difficult to manufacture with
conventional projection technology we
can manufacture a 120 nanometer guide
structure with normal projection
technology and this structure will align
three of the 40 nanometer guide lines in
between so the materials are doing the
most difficult fine patterning and we
call this whole approach directed
self-assembly the challenge with
directed self-assembly is that the whole
system needs to align almost perfectly
because any tiny defect in the structure
could cause a transistor failure and
because there are billions of
transistors in our circuit we need an
almost molecular ly perfect system but
we're going to extraordinary measures to
achieve this from the cleanliness of our
chemistry to the careful processing of
these materials in the semiconductor
factory to remove even the smallest
nanoscopic defects so directed
self-assembly is an exciting new
disruptive technology
but it is still in the development stage
but we growing in confidence that we
could in fact introduce it to the
semiconductor industry as a
revolutionary new manufacturing process
in just the next few years and if we can
do this if we're successful we'll be
able to continue with the cost-effective
miniaturization of transistors continue
with the spectacular expansion of
computing and the digital revolution and
what's more this could even be the dawn
of a new era of molecular manufacturing
how cool is that thank you
[Applause]
[Music]